[Música]
y hablamos del polémico lenguaje
inclusivo la variación
morfológica y sintáctica del español que
busca dar cabida a otras identidades de
género más allá de hombres y mujeres
esto ha generado un fuerte rechazo de
los expertos en la lengua el lenguaje se
define como poderoso dinámico y para
muchos es sinónimo de la forma en la que
nosotros vemos el mundo las palabras son
las bases para nuestra conexión con
otros con nuestro entorno y también con
nuestra propia identidad para los
activistas de la comunidad lgtb más
identificarnos en nuestros propios
términos y ser reconocidos como la
gradas e inclusivas forma parte de la
democratización del lenguaje y también
del orgullo de ser quiénes somos pero
para los expertos en la lengua se trata
de algo innecesario y algunos lo
catalogan de la destrucción del español
en nuestro caso por eso quiero saludar
en este momento a fernando vilches
vivancos él es profesor titular de
lengua española de la universidad rey
juan carlos de madrid en españa gracias
profesor fernando por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le empiezo destrucción de la lengua o
lucha por la igualdad
no ninguna de las dos cosas géneros raúl
yo creo que esto es una moda pasajera
vamos a ver es evidente que las personas
de sexo diferente a los dos habituales
tienen que sentirse representadas en la
sociedad claro que sí pero porque no va
a ser una persona que sea binaria que no
se sienta hombre o mujer que sea
transgénero porque no van a tener
presencia de esos días claro que sí lo
tenemos que hacer es respetar sus
derechos pero los derechos no empiezan
por el tema lingüístico desde minute y
lista voy a decirles al respecto a pedir
muchas disculpas por lo que voy a decir
ahora porque tiene una palabra un
poquito fuerte no en mi universidad yo
estudiaba fíjese usted jovencito yo ya
tengo muchos años había un cartel que
decía coma un millón de moscas no
pueden equivocarse por lo tanto el hecho
de que muchísima gente o una parte de la
sociedad esté pidiendo a gritos este
cambio en la lengua no es un cambio
positivo porque yo doy clase en una
facultad de comunicación y a los alumnos
les enseño a ley no me ha del lenguaje
usted raúl tiene un programa excelente
por cierto donde de vez en cuando lo veo
además ella imagen un lenguaje muy
bonito porque es que el colombia sobre
el español precioso ahora he visto con
rosa que me decir que usted que sí que
le informe de otra cosa de dicho cien
por cien que lo que se mi hija que damos
este domingo anita cariño 100% que no es
diseño es totalmente sí pues ese luego
de tan precioso que ustedes tienen
tenemos que conservarlo es decir si yo
empiezo a feminizar o hacer esa inter el
medio entre el mayor en el femenino con
el todas todos todos
y yo que la jueza es jueza y además es
impertinente y además es ignorante y
estoy destrozando un idioma que tiene
siglos y que compartimos que ojo que le
digo a los telespectadores de france de
la televisión que no es el idioma de
españa el español sobre todo el más
importante es el español de
hispanoamérica que es un porcentaje
mucho mayor que el nuestro entonces la
economía del lenguaje se cierra un
saludo hola a todos los colombianos y
colombianas amigos y amigas espectadores
y ahora si usted pierde un tiempo
precioso raúl y no puede ser cosa es
decir que no es necesario en este
momento por ejemplo cambiar el lenguaje
usted cree que si pueda evolucionar a
otra cosa yo lo que sí quiere o raúl
firmemente fíjese que tengo en casa una
mujer una perra y una hija o sea que yo
lo del género femenino lo respeto lo
admiro y además vivo estupendamente con
tres cabezas fenomenal en mi casa lo que
sí creo que hay que evitar es la
excesiva presencia del masculino en
nuestro idioma en el español claro que
sí es decir que en un libro 'historia un
niño estudia que el hombre vuelve a la
tierra hace millones de años que era un
crimen está la rueda que el hombre se
hace sedentario que el hombre se vuelve
agricultor no hubiera usted el ser
humano es decir si hablamos de hombres y
mujeres la mujer es mucho más
inteligente color más intuitiva y estoy
convencido raúl de que la rueda la
inventó una mujer una hembra de la
especie porque los hombres somos muy
brutos y muy bestias y nos gusta tirar
del carro a lo burro esto si una mujer
se apiadó de su pp de su pacto de su
raúl dijo lane mental la rueda para que
no se gaste tan bien yo lo resumo
también en un chascarrillo desde mamá
mamá en el colegio me llaman idiota dice
quién es hijos de todos y todas mis
compañeros y compañeras vamos a ver si
el idioma que es algo que tiene que unir
nos da primero presencia a todo el mundo
por supuesto y respeto al cien por cien
a una persona y es que tiene el mismo
respeto que tengo yo que soy otro sexual
ni más ni menos un ser humano de acuerdo
el idioma hay que la revolución del
mismo no se entiende aún no podemos
revolucionar el idioma de un día para
otro de ume para otro sueño para otro
porque entonces yo no podía ir a
colombia a entenderme como me entendía
ayer estupendamente con con su
productora quedé encantado es decir
vendimos perfectamente hicimos una
prueba magnífica para el día de hoy no
hay diez chicas hemos salido de esta
manera con revolución raúl misterio nos
entenderíamos tanto ahora fernando lo
que lo que entiendo que quiere decir es
mejor usar el término de persona el ser
humano que en lugar de una o una equis
en nuestro nuestro lenguaje
por supuesto radio lo que quiere ver que
hay que dar presencia a todo el mundo de
acuerdo están hablando por ejemplo del
tratamiento de la discapacidad en
español pues en vez de decir un ciego un
invidente una persona ciega una persona
sordociega una persona con una
discapacidad intelectual la palabra
persona es excelente para empezar
segundo yo estoy convencido raúl de que
esta moda que aquí en españa lo llevan
sobre todo la izquierda donde podemos y
luego un poquito lo del suelo de ghana
casa no dicen hola chicos chicas amigos
amigas todos todas pero mucho menos
tories de acuerdo esto yo creo que esto
es una pose y aquí tienen los chicos
jóvenes en este inicio post no sé en
colombia como lo dirán por lo tanto lo
que hay que hacer es evitar la estrella
presenta el masculino yo es que tu libro
sobre el tema sobre el lenguaje jurídico
administrativo es un lenguaje de
especialidad y doy 13 recetas raúl 13
para evitar el excesivo a la excesiva
presencia del masculino en el idioma
español por supuesto que sí pero no
hagamos estos dobles ya por último usted
cree que es algo político esto es todo
del idioma inclusivo estos cien por cien
vale y si usted a rózsa cien por cien
veces y estoy convencido de que con esto
vamos a ver raúl distraemos los
verdaderos problemas que tiene el
colectivo el gtm que tiene que
encargarse les hacia de una vez por
todas y se tienen que acabar los días de
el de la mujer internet internacional
europeas del niño los días de de las
personas gays homosexual se tiene que
acabar con ese día porque no hay un día
del profesor tonto ni de esfuerzo
universitario internacional no lo hay
por tanto esto es absolutamente político
pero diga lo que está pasando en españa
usted están informando también de todo
lo internacional que tenemos un programa
volcán de acuerdo soy todos los días que
ustedes raúl verá que se informa sobre
la lava que sale por decir
que la lava cuando sale del volcán es
cuando baja por la ladera hasta llegar
para decir esta tontería es mejor no
informar pero ya ha visto usted alguna
información raúl desde españa que digan
lo que se está haciendo por parte de las
autoridades políticas del gobierno del
estado a favor de estas personas de
canarias no estamos distrayendo y con
este lenguaje con determinadas noticias
raúl disfrutaremos el problema de fondo
que es que las personas con un sexo
determinado diferente al tradicional
tienen absolutamente mismo derecho a
vivir que los demás ni más ni menos